how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we are officially in phase four of the
MCU last week phase four began with the
Black Widow trailer starting us off with
an awesome
bang the trailer was awesome it was
packed full of action stuffed with
Easter eggs and left us with a lot of
questions as well like as taskmaster
Hawkeye no but it also did answer some
questions for us like hopper really is
still alive and in Russia but one of the
biggest things that everybody seems to
be talking about right now
with the Black Widow trailer is the
mutant Easter Egg that's right a mutant
Easter Egg in the Black Widow teaser
trailer I did a quick video on this
right after the trailer came out but
we've learned some new information since
then and it appears very apparent that a
mutant is going to be in the Black Widow
movie so we're gonna break down just who
this mutant could be and luckily for us
it's pretty much narrowed down to two
people
quick reminder to subscribe but when
notifications turned on like the video
and leave a comment down below so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 you can also
click the link in the description down
below for your chance to win an Infiniti
Gotland so in the Black Widow trailer
towards the end of it there is one scene
with David Arbor who plays Alexi Shasta
cough / Red Guardian where he's breaking
out of a maximum-security prison now we
know that Black Widow is going to take
place between the events of Captain
America Civil War and the events of
Avengers in game but we also know that
it's going to explore Natasha's past so
we could probably expect some quick
flashbacks and even some major scenes
from her past which would explain why we
have this extremely de-aged Thunderbolt
Ross but in the trailer sometimes it's
hard to tell what's happening in the
past or in the present time that this
movie is taking place in but when Red
Guardian is breaking out of this prison
it does look like it's in the current
time when we see him break out of the
prison he's got the long hair he's got
the beard and he looks a little bit
overweight like they make fun of in the
trailer implying that this is in fact in
the current time of the movie but the
question about this scene is even though
Alexei Shostakovich the Red Guardian has
a version of the Super Soldier Serum in
him could he really break down this
super heavy-duty metal door to a
maximum-security prison
the answer is probably no in fact it's
been revealed that it actually was not
the red Guardian who kicked down this
door it turns out that he has
a little help from somebody with some
mutated genes and that person is Oliver
Richards otherwise known as the Dutch
giant he's the tallest actor in the
world coming in at seven foot two when
the Black Widow trailer first came out
he posted the day of about being in the
movie if you go to his Instagram right
now you can look up the Dutch giant and
see his marvel post he says oh yes
Marvel Black Widow trailer released in
May 2020 the Kingsmen is postponed to
the end of 2020 meaning that Black Widow
will be my first movie in the cinema he
then went on to talk about how he always
wanted to be in a Marvel film but he
thought that he would have to have a
better resume but alas this is going to
be his first movie ever
however funny thing about Instagram is
unlike Twitter when you post something
you can edit the text and this is not
what he originally said in his original
post and luckily I screenshot the
original post and can show you what
exactly he said his original post said
oh yes Marvel Black Widow trailer
released in May 2020 that part is the
same but the next line is different he
then goes on to say I do wonder who is
busting that door that line is no longer
in his Instagram post it has been edited
out which means somebody asked him to
remove it and the only people who could
have asked him to remove that are Marvel
Studios and as you can see in one of the
pictures it's of the door being burst
down and that's still up so this is 100%
him kicking down that door in the Black
Widow trailer and he actually revealed a
little bit more in the comment section
in the comment somebody replied talking
about a pre-cool with the same actress
as a character we saw died in the last
film just fails off this should have
been put in Phase two and the Dutch
giant replied maybe but it might have
Clues for the next phase just like
Captain Marvel this implies that mutants
are going to be hinted at and set up in
Black Widow they're not going to full-on
introduce the x-men but they are going
to talk about or mention mutants this
was clearly a spoiler Marvel Studios
wanted everybody to think that it was
red guardian breaking down that door
breaking out of the prison but it wasn't
it was the Dutch Giant and now we know
so why are they trying to keep this a
secret probably because his character is
going to be the first mutant in the MCU
now in the phase four reveal at San
Diego
makan Kevin Feige name-dropped mutants
at the end of his panel at San Diego
comic-con he said we didn't even have
time to talk about mutants they were
making black panther - Captain Marvel -
I didn't even have time to talk about
the Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about a
mutant
[Applause]
now everybody thought that he was
probably going to talk about the mutants
coming in the future but perhaps he was
going to say that they're actually going
to start making their appearances in
phase four
starting with Black Widow the first film
of phase four and that seems to be what
we're getting with the Dutch giant so
the question is what mutant could the
seven foot two inches actor be plain
well fortunately for us there's really
only a couple of choices that make sense
one is Ursa Major who fits very well
into the story that I've already talked
about that I'll talk about briefly again
and the other is the juggernaut who also
coincidentally fits very well into the
story as well so let's talk about how
these mutants fit into the storyline of
Black Widow and why they make perfect
sense Ursa Major is extremely easy to
tie into the story of Black Widow
especially given Ursa majors history
with red guardian so red Guardian is
essentially the Russian Captain America
the Russians managed to get their hands
on a type of Super Soldier Serum
manipulated it just a little bit and the
result was their very own Captain
America for Russia titled the red
Guardian you would think it would be
Captain Russia but no it's the red
Guardian now like I said it's sort of a
makeshift Super Soldier Serum it's not
really the same as Captain America's
it's not as strong which is why you see
the red Guardian kind of out of shape in
the film
you got fit but nonetheless he is or he
was Russia's Captain America and the Red
Guardian was a part of the winter guard
who was essentially Russia's response to
the Avengers
so the winter guard is Russia's Avengers
and guess who was on the winter guard
with Red Guardian Ursa Major both were
members of basically the Russian
Avengers now in the comics the Red
Guardian would eventually die the mantle
would be taken up by somebody else but
Ursa Major would go on to get locked in
a prison in black sound kind of familiar
so I'm assuming that the Red Guardian
doesn't actually die in the MCU but gets
locked in the prison with Ursa Major as
well now her major is a mutant that has
the ability to transform into a giant
bear while he's in his bear State he
retains all of his human intelligence
personality and his ability to speak
he's essentially smart Hulk just in bear
form however if he does stay in bear
form for a very long time he starts to
lose control over the human side but a
huge seven foot two giant mutant bear
could break down that door that we see
in the Black Widow trailer and again
like I said given Ursa majors history
with the Red Guardian and the winter
guard it does seem very likely that they
would be in that prison together they
were most likely on some type of mission
for the winter guard together where
something went wrong and they ended up
being thrown in prison maybe something
similar to what happened in Captain
America's Civil War where half of the
Avengers were thrown in jail for the
sokovia accords so he fits very well
into the storyline not to mention he was
also a member of the Black Widow ops
program which was a program where they
cloned Black Widow after she died in the
comics so there are a ton of connections
here that make it pretty easy for this
actor to be playing the mutant Ursa
Major not to mention that in his photo
he's also wearing a type of sash that
looks like it's made out of bear fur so
that could be him hinting that he is
playing Ursa Major however like I also
mentioned in the beginning it could be
another mutant the one and only
juggernaut again the Dutch giant is a
7-foot - bodybuilder perfect to play the
role of the juggernaut if you do not
want him to be CGI and based off of what
we know from Marvel already they
probably don't want him to be CGI but
the juggernaut could definitely break
down that door to the prison
and he is a great segue to introduce the
rest of the x-men because he is Charles
Xavier stepbrother in x-men the last and
they make no mention of this but in
Deadpool - the juggernaut says that he
wears the helmet because of his
wheelchair brother and in the comics
they are Step Brothers the juggernaut is
known once he's captured to be kept in
high-security prisons a lot it's pretty
much the only way to keep somebody like
the juggernaut maintained but perhaps
the Red Guardian could have helped him
escape inside the prison so that
juggernaut could help him escape outside
of the prison not only could this be the
perfect role for all of our Richards but
then you could have a perfect link to
Charles Xavier the founder of the x-men
so if Black Widow is going to hint at
and set up the mutants and the MCU which
it very well seems like they are then
having a super well known and loved
character appear in Black Widow such as
the juggernaut that also connects to one
of the main and most famous x-men
Professor Xavier then the juggernaut
could be perfect for Black Widow now
granted he probably won't have any of
his armor on he probably won't have his
helmet at this point in time it's most
likely just going to be a little hint
that this person is the juggernaut and
he is a mutant now if this happens
they'll most likely just call him by his
name Cain Marko in the comics him and
his stepbrother Charles Xavier joined
the military
so perhaps Cain Marko was in the
military somehow ended up in Russia and
was captured but what do you think makes
more sense does it make more sense to
have Ursa Major given his connection to
red guardian or do you think it would be
better to introduce somebody huge like
juggernaut who has a direct connection
to Charles Xavier which one would you
prefer let me know in the comments down
below also be sure to subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date with everything relating to
the MCU and give the video a like so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 the winner gets
to choose I'm picking a new winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers also if you'd like a chance
to win an Infinity Gauntlet you can
click the link in the description down
below don't forget to use code cosmic @
G fuel comm for 30% off your G fuel and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
wolf